The Joe Rogan Experience no I out of the
life I have to admit it wasn't always
cost effective but I I lived in a
gimmick but yeah but it's such a fun
life yeah what year did you start like
what what year did you make your first
like pro wrestling matches 73 73. I
started trading in in Fall of 72
and I made my I had my first match in
January
73. those are the old days man the
Kowalski days
Crusher Bruiser yeah I mean but you
started wrestling after the plane crash
right no plane crash was in 75. oh wow
tell us about the plane crash
um we were going from
Charlotte to Wilmington North Carolina
for Outdoors Show 10 000 Legion Stadium
where Dr Michael's from
um it's first time at Michael Jordan
in Wilmington and um
we like what happened ultimately is he
took five of us on the plane and he we
didn't know at the time he was carrying
no fuel because we were 1400 pounds over
gross right so we get there and hit a
little bit of a headwind or
between seven and eight thousand it's
not a pressurized plan so that's not
310. and um
he did what's called past the point of
no return he should have landed in
Raleigh and refilled but he's looking
and say it's 100 miles right so
unbeknownst to us
the guy right in front of me Johnny
Valentine who got paralyzed
kept looking at the gas station looking
back at me and going uh I got to go
Johnny at that dry sense of humor well
we're flying along all of a sudden the
right engine goes
maybe like six times over like you said
in the movies and
Bingo pin right I went he reaches
down he pulls up the reserve natural
reaction there is no reserve gas left
engine went beer boom
and instead of which what flew into a
Orchard Tree Orchards right normally a
little cartwheel a small aircraft we're
going so fastly toward down
and landed a railroad makement stuck at
the ground at 230 miles an hour so we
were probably going you know well over
and we're just uh literally 200 yards
from the runway
wow
they tried and you're you he died and
you never regained conscious and two
chicks came both engaged to him don't
don't knock out at the door
at the hospital door
oh boy I told the guy he said he goes
Joey Yuna could talk all day so they're
putting this in the middle in the
ambulance right it's like the old
military style not like the ones today
that are like like a hospital room right
you're putting in a rack right and he
goes I think we might lose this one so I
go I told the guy I said I think he's
talking about me I said man go my
shaving kit to the letter to a chick
named Sheila said tell Sheila I love her
or not to come see me
last night
I think I showed up 10 years later the
Manchester you remember me I'm the guy
that got the letter for you thanks
so how bad did you get injured in the
accident wrote my back three places T10
11 and 12.
fractured the actual bones of the
compression Frederick yeah I used to be
a six foot two so they had to fuse your
back
nope no surgery at all really yeah they
just didn't think I'd ever wrestle again
and I I'm you know that goes that was
what we're gonna do right
they said you're never gonna wrestle
again yeah
[Laughter]
I was in 75. would you say when was it
like October of 75 and I was back in the
ring in March of
76. yeah
I went from 255 to 180 back to 218. wow
but it never got myself to land flat on
my back again ever you know everybody
knows the land of my hip and my side
yeah because of your back injury yeah
just couldn't get myself to land flat so
the promoter I was wrestling
said if you don't take a backdrop that's
really flip over a guy shoulder and go
up in here like six seven feet boom I'm
Gonna Make You wrestle an hour every
night
you do
so I'll go after two weeks of wrestling
and you know and some of the crowds back
then were
250 300 people you know I mean five
bucks ringside Fisherville North
Carolina or Fisherville Virginia middle
of nowhere right one hour every night
finally I said damn it I'm just gonna
take the backdrop throw me in hit the
road took it boom
that was over but I I just couldn't give
myself a landslide on my back when you
did what happened were you all right it
was fine yeah so it was just
psychological all psychological yeah
Jesus Christ